finds the seam pass inside athena kumpo
he's surrounded
back out holiday off the dribble
tucker open for three got it eight
three-pointers
six on the shot clock middleton throws
it up and the tenecupo
able to get it to go
[Applause]
middleton
holiday another long three got it drew
holiday lighting it up here in the first
half
in game four but comes out red-hot
including knocking down
a couple of he's played 41 minutes
already
[Applause]
crowder comes up to crowd him shot clock
at six
middleton two-pointer puts it in and the
foul
chris middleton a chance for a
three-point play
and the lead back up to nine
similar to what we saw phoenix doing
with pat connaughton
and a big time jumper
by middleton
except 85 points and there's five and a
half remaining in the third
holiday conan three-pointer from the
corner it's good
pat connaughton four for six from
downtown
pulls back middleton wants it good ball
going on how middleton comes out to get
it
on the drive step back three-pointer
that's good
a much-needed bucket from phoenix
johnson's second three-pointer is back
to 10.
lopez inside and holiday with his 11th
assist
but you're right coach middleton takes
the trap delivers it
the true holiday how they allows the
play to develop until
lopez gives them a target they were
coming
but he got away baseline
[Applause]
[Music]
stolen by holiday
[Applause]
what a turnaround a chance to take the
lead and the turnover
as the bucks now up by three in a free
throw gets into the pitcher comes up
with the strip
turning the basketball over and then off
to the races
could have held it out instead made the
right read throws it up where only
giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact and bad
decision to foul because this would make
it
a four-point game with 13.5 remaining
phoenix still has a timeout
[Music]
middleton just won for seven so far they
get down two for eight and a 16 point
lead
what are we gonna get tonight here we go
drew holiday first shot of the night
phoenix is 7 for 12. milwaukee
6 for 11.
[Applause]
[Music]
bridges chasing middleton finds it open
again he nails the hook that's able to
tell chris paul when he's wrong and got
to be better
and chris paul you lose your credibility
if you're not willing to embrace
when when somebody else is coaching you
good looking chopper from true holiday
where's the rebound meanwhile mike
woonholzer is downsized just a little
bit
put holiday back in the game took portis
out
holiday nearly throws it away
middleton shot clock at seven his drive
in a lane floats it up and in
he said we just competed harder
sometimes it is that simple
well it is the greatest adjustment i
think adjustment
as giannis gets fouled first half
9.6 assists giannis is already tired and
walking up the floor
in transition i saw that early
he did play the entire first quarter as
middleton
nails the throat that hot start this is
a couple there
the lead for phoenix is 14 opening
minute here in the second
[Music]
and i think they should post brook lopez
some as holiday
with
[Applause]
[Music]
which one of these teams are going to
put together consecutive stops
try to win it on the defensive end
middleton goes right at chris paul
turns the tables 16 now for middleton
lopez leads the body of chris paul gets
a wide open low
holiday oh nifty moves score here in the
third quarter devin booker 12 chris
middleton nine
overall it's a three-point milwaukee
league and tenecupo
beautiful feed another assist briana's
his sixth of the game
already 11 points for holiday craig
misses the three
almost at his own rebound but commenting
got a hold lopez
down the other end for the slam shooting
91
[Applause]
spins using his height shoots over it
scores
[Applause]
drew holland very aggressive start finds
portis to corner three that's good from
bobby porters
he missed another post up he got a roll
and then a second shot right there
already ten points for ayton as holliday
already
14 points
chris paul turns shoots misses lopez the
rebound
[Music]
connorton takes a pass fires connects
again
that connaughton three for three from
downtown
[Applause]
hooker trying to fight over the screen
holiday stops
two-pointer rolls around and drops
through and espn
holidays jump shot is good
[Music]
moving without the basketball coach you
always talked about his ability to slash
and cut
holiday with the steal took it away from
booker and with tucker out holiday on
him
and knocks down the three drew holiday
now with 23 points
[Applause]
[Music]
holiday makes his move drives on eight
falling away shot is up and good
she got to concentrate on trying to get
some stops
[Music]
holiday searching holiday has been in
command
all night long trying to draw the foul
paul knocks it away holliday gets it
back lay up he banks it